ballotage nom féminin signifiant
s'engage en politique il ya ballottage
quand aucun candidat n'a obtenu le
nombre de voix requis pour être élu dès
le premier tour
soit pour une élection municipale la
majorité absolue des suffrages exprimés
et un nombre de suffrages égal à un
quart des inscrits on parle de
ballottage quand il ya du vent dans les
voiles en général le ballottage est
réservé au maire sortant toujours c'est
en fait un résultat de normand en
ballottage favorable
le candidat sera peut-être bien élu
ayant obtenu le meilleur score il n'a vu
vers la victoire sur une mer presque du
en ballottage défavorable il sera
peut-être bien par élu avec le moins bon
score lacombe est grande le mal de mer
lui donne alors une jolie couleur vert
bouteille des temps pour lui d'en jeter
lignes arrières de bouteilles car en
ballottage défavorable le candidat suit
de très près son pire ennemi ce pire qui
veut s'emparer des bijoux de la couronne
en l'occurrence la mairie pendant
l'entre-deux-tours chacun bas l'abordage
du navire des listes non qualifiés
tentant de rallier à leur cause les
électeurs avant donner à fond de cale
parfois un autre flibustiers entre dans
le combat qui devient alors une
triangulaire le vainqueur en général et
celui qui a largué les amarres
les deux autres soirées dans les abysses
du combat politique comme quoi pour
réussir en politique il vaut mieux avoir
le pied marin sa forte